it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us russia must be pushed out of the
whole of ukraine that from the foreign
secretary liz truss who's called on
western allies to double down on their
support for the country with both heavy
weapons and air power and here in
westminster the conservatives are facing
yet another sex scandal as a tory mp is
referred to the parliamentary watchdog
over claims that he watched pornography
on his mobile phone whilst in the house
of commons chamber we'll be getting the
response of the defense secretary ben
wallace in just a moment and later this
hour i'll be speaking to the heads of
the company that owns the as of style
steel plant believed to be the last
ukrainian stronghold in the perceived
city of mario paul and which is said to
be close to catastrophe it is thursday
28th of april
time for courage not caution the foreign
secretary says russia must be completely
driven out of ukraine and calls on
western allies to step up their support
we're doubling down
we will keep going further and faster to
push russia out of the whole of ukraine
the united nations secretary general is
in keeve today for talks with ukraine's
president and we're live here in moldova
where there are fears that this could be
a new front in the war
shocking and unacceptable the minister
for safeguarding women tells sky news
that a conservative mp should be
expelled from the party if allegations
he watched pornography in the commons
chamber are proved true
action needs to be taken i very much
hope that this person will be
we'll see him out of parliament out of
the party
police raid homes and offices in london
and the isle of man is part of a
criminal investigation into the supply
of government ppe
a man is due in court today charged with
murdering mother of two katy kenyon as
police continue their search for
claims that johnny depp lost his role in
pirates of the caribbean because of the
abuse allegations by amber hart as the
actor's defamation trial continues
also ahead on the programme
we'll be speaking to the former
australian prime minister kevin rudd on
whether the united states and china are
on a collision course to war
and winner turned giver uh we'll speak
to the multi-millionaire who's already
donated half of her 150 million fortune
because she's addicted to helping
[Music]
morning all the foreign secretary says
western allies must double down on
support for ukraine and push russia out
of the whole of the country liz trust
has also called on western allies to
send tanks planes and other heavy
weapons to ukraine her comments come as
the u.n secretary general antonio
gutierrez has arrived in the ukrainian
capital for a meeting with president
zielinski with the goal of securing
evacuation corridors for civilians
trapped in besieged cities like mariupol
let's just have a listen to what the fun
secretary had to say at the mansion
house last night
ukraine deserves nothing less than a
landmark international effort to rebuild
their towns and cities regenerate their
industries and secure their freedom for
the long term
we're doubling down
we will keep going further and faster to
push russia out of the whole of ukraine
and this has to be a catalyst for wider
change
we need to apply this tough stance to
the threats that are emerging beyond
ukraine
i will speak now disguise mark stone
joining us now from the transnistria
moldova border i'm good to see you this
morning mark i mean in part
the reason that you are where you are is
the reason that liz trust is talking
about pushing vladimir putin out of the
entirety of the country it does appear
that his ambitions are not solely
limited to ukraine
yeah remember there were plenty of
people who didn't believe that vladimir
putin would go as far as he did when he
tempted um eight weeks ago
to take keeve uh itself so the fact that
russian generals that the kremlin are
talking about this potential land bridge
that would bring their forces along the
south of the uh of ukraine
and uh to bring um to bring the um
to bring their forces to the to the west
of ukraine potentially to link up with
this breakaway state of transnistria
which is a a part of moldova but it is
self-declared independent it's just down
there you can see beyond those two wind
turbines is a vast power station that
power station is within transnistria
and it provides all the energy for
moldova
so the russians could quite easily cut
off the supplies of energy to moldova as
they have already done
in terms of russian gas to both poland
and bulgaria so there are
there are very many different um
fronts in this war literally military
fronts but also
attempts by russia to use its influence
elsewhere to be able um to put pressure
on the west so that is why liz truss is
suggesting that that the west needs to
double down in terms of the diplomacy
well um we know that the secretary
general of the united nations is now in
kiev he's leaving
right now to head to the towns of
butcher and urban
those towns that where such horrific um
murder took place
it is something that the secretary
general has already talked about and he
will visit those two towns i imagine
that will be a pretty poignant moment
later on this afternoon uh he will hold
meetings with the ukrainian president
vladimir zelensky
in terms of further east mariupol
there are still uh strikes taking place
there there are still air strikes by the
russians taking place and clashes with
the ukrainian forces in the azov style
steel works that despite the fact that
vladimir putin said that his forces
would not strike the steel works he told
the secretary general of the u.n that
when he was in moscow and yet on the
ground the facts appear to differ so on
many fronts at the moment
there is
there are still clashes taking place and
the language coming out of the kremlin
is particularly concerning
mark once we have you we can we
constantly talk and you've just
mentioned it there about the creation of
these evacuation corridors i mean
whenever they have been set up they have
brought out with them a fraction of the
total that they have wanted what has
largely been the reason for that has it
just been russian abstinence
a very good question and it's it's very
frustrating from our point of view
because we cannot get into mariupol i
think that's something worth stressing
is that it's not possible for western
journalists just to go there the only
way you get in
is if the kremlin allows you in from the
russian
side and that has not been happening um
there are humanitarian corridors and
we've witnessed many hundreds of people
who have left mariupol over the course
of the past
eight weeks but there are many many more
who are unable to leave simply because
it's not safe and there are multiple
checkpoints as you drive out of
mariupola remember it's a vast vast
country and so the journey the distances
are huge
and multiple russian checkpoints at
which very often these buses and private
vehicles if people have got them uh are
turned back and so that there are two
distinct problems in mariupol uh
there is the those that are in within
the town at the city itself and there
are still many thousands there and then
there are those that are holed up in the
steel works uh those that are in the
steel works they are not able to get out
at all at the moment absolutely uh
impossible for them to leave those that
are in the town itself they can get out
only when humanitarian corridors are
open and the russians are saying oh look
we always open them but they open them
for people to go into russia they don't
open them
all the time for people to go further
west into ukraine
mark many thanks indeed
i'm very pleased to say the defense
secretary ben wallace joins us once
again in the program good to see you
this morning minister um i wonder if
actually we might start with a quick
question on on where mark was the
translator in a moldova border how
concerned are you that vladimir putin's
ambitions stretch much further than
ukraine well i think he's always had
these sort of ambitions that he
wrote about and spoke about
for years actually about the russian
people or the ancient people of russian
that has led him to be sort of ethnic
nationalist when he drives towards sort
of geographic ambition it's one of the
justifications of why he thought he
would be able to walk into ukraine and
be welcomed and then obviously there are
pockets of other russian speakers that
he feels uh potentially in the same way
that you know the nazis felt the
sacrifice war that they have a sort of
ownership of these people
uh
and so there is definitely a sense that
you know you can see in his current
statement he is in almost in desperation
trying to broaden this either with
threats or indeed
with potential false flags or or attacks
we we don't know the details of the
attacks that happened yesterday uh in
trying easter there are a number of
players in transparency there are
separatists there are russians
everything so we're not too sure
but of course it's another step if it is
russia behind it of of another example
of his strategic blunder because you
know for romania uh moldova is
incredibly important so all you do is
harden the resolve of something like
romania we saw him switch off the gas to
bulgaria yesterday which was a country
that was sort of on the fence well the
consequence of that is the complete
opposite is is this in part why the
foreign secretary kind of alluded
yesterday to the fact i mean this
conflict this war in ukraine could last
a number of years it could last
perhaps a decade well i think it it's
certainly the case that putin having
failed and nearly all his objectives may
seek to consolidate what he's got sort
of fortify and dig in as he did in 2014
and just be a sort of cancerous growth
within the country of ukraine
and make it very hard for people to move
them out of those fortified positions so
i think it's really about if if if we
want this to not happen we have to help
ukrainians effectively get the limpet
off the rock
and keep the momentum pushing them back
but but when liz trust says you know we
have to push russia out of the whole of
ukraine i mean we should really really
need to clarify this is she talking
about crimea
well the international community
believes russia should leave ukraine the
international community has condemned
russia for its invasion of crimea which
was illegal in 2014
its invasion of dynesque
recognizing it as illegal is somewhat
different we don't recognize it and
we've constantly said that russia should
leave
ukraine sovereign territory so that
hasn't changed we if you remember we did
a freedom of navigation exercise hms
defender last year in the black sea we
don't recognize their ownership so so
are you contemplating a point in this
conflict where we will continue to
support the ukrainians as they push into
crimea well i i think i mean you know
there's a long way to go before you
create questions your crimea i think
what i would certainly say is you know
we we are supporting ukraine's sovereign
integrity we've done that all along that
of course includes crimea and danesque
but you know first and foremost let's
get russia out of where they are now in
its invasion plans
and help ukraine resolve and that's if
you remember the minsk agreement which
russia has basically ripped up was all
about trying to resolve those two
occupied territories uh but the key
thing here is to continue to support
ukraine sovereign integrity and their
ability to defend themselves it appears
that you do have a bit of an ally in the
foreign secretary as you would expect of
course but when she said uh in her
speech you know that that two percent in
terms of nato spending should be the
floor and not the ceiling i mean you
would want more money at the moment i'm
just wondering has the treasury served
to provide you with funds
to replace the weapons and equipment
that we've sent to ukraine to cover the
cost of sending troops to the border
yet for now the treasury has absolutely
reimbursed us or are reimbursing us for
for the both the kit we're providing uh
and indeed you know the operational cost
which is which is what you would expect
and i think you know rishi sunika's
chancellor's definitely stood by us on
on those issues so right now in the here
and now we don't have a challenge to our
funding of course the future is a
different thing the the effects of
inflation on our budget but also how far
we want to go in support of ukraine will
of course of course have costs but you
know rishi's been incredibly supportive
on that and and we're continuing on that
direction would you like to see more
than the kind of the 2.1 i think if you
had any secretary of state of any
department sitting on your sure but i've
got you and asking asking them if they'd
like more money for the department of
course i'd like more money for my
department but they're likely to have a
labour secretary of state would say that
any sector
but
you are let's be fair about it
and
you are involved in a war and no other
government department is and you have
support you are supplying weapons and
and
material to a war so just on that basis
in the right now here and now for now
for this year's budget i am absolutely
set and for next year's you know we put
in a bid uh to the chancellor uh
for a four-year budget uh those first
two years are sort of
over uh i have always said as the threat
changes our demands change that can mean
can go up and down
what has changed since the integrated
review and indeed the defense command
paper is the threat has changed insofar
as while we identified russia is
basically the number one threat
the fact that president putin has gone
even further does make us all in a much
more insecure place and that's why the
next spending round and discussions
about the budget for the defense will of
course include how threat has changed
but right now uh you know the reforms to
the armed forces the support issues
giving me for ammunition etcetera means
that we're in a position where we can
meet our demand just reading this
morning's kind of defense intelligence
briefing a focus on the black sea in the
fleet there and i would suggest that you
know 20 vessels there is in part where
we are considering sending as a
brimstone well yeah so the reporting
slightly amiss the brimstone we are
sending is the ground brimstone right so
that will be used over the ground uh the
the you have to have a different type of
brimstone for maritime but the ones
we're sending at the moment to that but
we have said we will source
and supply if we can anti-ship missiles
it's incredibly important that the grain
that affects us all the food prices does
get to get out of ukraine that the
russians can't control the black sea
it's not theirs anymore that it is the
turks and the romanians the bulgarians
but they think somehow they can control
it and therefore making sure that the
russian ships are not used to bombard
cities is important and the minister
whenever we speak generally we spend the
vast majority of our time on your brief
today there are a couple of other
stories around that i think think demand
a little bit of attention um the high
court ruling yesterday in its judicial
review of the the the unlawful nature of
the decision taken by matt hancock as
regards care homes is it finally time
for us to dispose of the notion as he
himself said that there was any sort of
a protective ring thrown around care
homes well i think look
let's let's cast our mind back and this
is really important remember i remember
certainly you know again in the defense
space but there was a clamor for
assistance we were learning incredibly
fast about this pat this virus
it was coming thick and fast there were
massive concerns about the scale
of infection the death rates if you
remember the about the same time
everyone wanted ventilators you know the
medical advice was ventilators what
would be needed i remember using the
military to unpack thousands of
ventilators that that came in from
around the world and then consequently
we learned that that was not really the
key part of the treatment so so that's
why we're having this big public inquiry
that's why we're going to have an
inquiry into
covid it's really important we learn
those lessons of course that is a court
case and a court ruling
matt hancock's put his own statement
outside he has i mean he said he said
that the the court case comprehensively
clears ministers of of any wrongdoing
the judgment said that those uncharted
had had simply failed
i mean
i've went through i don't know if you've
had the time to read the 75-page
judgment i did i read it last night and
despite mr hancock's characterization of
it comprehensively clearing ministers it
clearly states that he he acted
unlawfully and in doing so in not paying
heed to asymptomatic transmission of 19
people died in care homes well look
we've been very clear that we are you
know we apologize for all deaths about
in this that could have been better
handled i know matt did his own
interview recently saying he had some
regrets but i fundamentally i bet he
does look look look
imagine if we kept asymmetric people in
hospital what would that have done
to other patients as well i mean this
was not a yes it happened in a
care home setting we took a lot of steps
around care homes if you remember we got
criticized not so long ago for insisting
that you had to be vaccinated to work in
a care home there was a huge amount of
criticism i i wouldn't say there was as
much criticism of the decision to send
people potentially with covert 19 into
one of the most risky environments for
covert transmission i mean the prime
minister repeated this statement
yesterday prime minister's questions
that the government had not been told
about by public health england about
asymptomatic transmission i mean that is
just nonsense i want to show you
a quote from sir patrick violence uh the
chief scientific
advisor
and he says this he was on the today
program on march the 13th that year he
said it looks quite likely that there is
some degree of asymptomatic transmission
there's definitely quite a lot of
transmission very early on in the
disease when there are very mild
symptoms he was talking about it i knew
about it my colleagues here at sky news
knew about it for the prime minister and
indeed the health secretary to maintain
that they knew nothing about it because
public health england didn't give them
an explicit warning i mean it's just
this court case proves that not to be
true well look i think as i've said
there is going to be an inquiry so we
can actually see the whole thing in
context we can we can study what you're
saying about whether the the prime
minister and others were told we can see
whether they acted on it i certainly
remember using military personnel to try
and take testing to care homes so we
could we could make sure we
no one is denying that the armed forces
predicted
the point was the government did
recognize their issues and care homes
which is why they asked the army for
example to assist that i i think you
know look there's a court case i haven't
read the 75-page ruling uh you know it's
it you know
definitely the welfare of people in this
country is top of my agenda the prime
minister misled the house yesterday when
he said that he did not know about
asymptomatic transmission that was his
chief scientific advisor there well they
just switched on the today program and
i'm not suggesting people do but you
know well i i think first and foremost
what i would say is that quote doesn't
talk about asymmetric it says mild
symptoms right so so some people have no
symptoms who had covid uh i mean
i will read it and we read it again it
looks quite likely there is some degree
of asymptomatic transmission yeah well
look look
i haven't read the report sure i've just
come on the program no no i fully
understand it's a 75-page report matt
hancock's put a statement out we're
having a full inquiry to get to the
bottom of all the lessons learned to
have a look at what happened but i need
to just take you and your viewers back
to remember those stages you know it was
unknown no one knew about the variance
you know we were learning fast and
furiously about exactly what to do and
there were many situations that will
almost lose lose if you were damned if
you did and you were damned if you
didn't and i think it's really important
to remember that you know the government
was also grappling at the time with do
we have enough ppe do we have enough
ventilated all those things some of
those things turn out to be the wrong
course of effort based on advice or
based on no advice because there want
any and i think we should just not
forget the mass
uh worry in this state indeed off the
pandemic and of course you are not matt
hancock there is of course a standing
invitation of history if mr hancock
wants to come on and explain himself but
i do want to ask about perhaps perhaps
one of the most ridiculous stories i
have heard in recent times that a
conservative colleague of yours was
caught sitting in the house of commons
chamber next to apparently a female
minister watching pornography
well there is no place for pornography
in any workplace i mean people are there
to do their job and you know i know that
the chief whip has referred that
complaint to
to the the panel or the conduct
authority and and look we'll look into
that and and if there's any action to be
done then there should be action taken i
don't think there's any excuse you don't
sit in your workplace looking at
pornography that's well your colleague
damian green did that's what got him
sacked from cabinet what
well there was a result there was
i'm just saying i'm just saying if any
party has formed for this concern well
you know i used to hang on a sec i used
to uh
when i secured a minister my office in
the house of commerce was john
prescott's old office where he had his
christmas party he was the deputy leader
of the labour party and if we all
remember what that wasn't pornography
that was something else that went on in
that room i used to wonder
i used to wonder if it was the same desk
so you know i i think let's just be
clear here
same with sexual conduct there's a range
of allegations that go right across the
house go right across the parties you
know this is a problem i think about the
overall culture of the house of commons
it is late sitting long nights with bars
and that very often leads and it has
done for decades to behavioral
challenges and problems whether that's
too much drink we've remembered reports
of you know
why why do the armed forces deal with
this stuff better than you know our
elected representatives well
we still have problems in the armed
forces i mean you know look
one of the main missions of me is
defense secretary is we need to make the
armed forces far better for women
and their service we need to look after
complaints we need to take those
complaints seriously and action them
better we need to make sure we recruit
more women and make sure it's childcare
friendly for families in the army all
those sort of things are really
important so uh you know i don't i
wouldn't say make that comparison what i
would say is you know we all know what
happens when you mix long hours drink
and and pressure environment and i think
it's really important that we think
about ways to change the culture in the
house of commons so it doesn't happen
minister great to have you in the
program thanks for being with us thank
you
actually have a quick look through the
front pages of the papers and we start
this morning with the eye it leads with
the high court ruling criticizing the
government for discharging covert
patients to care homes during the pandem
well here is the metro just been
discussing this story um reports that
as yet unnamed conservative mp watched
pornography on his mobile phone in the
commons chamber a number of female
colleagues have complained
the times has the comments from the
foreign secretary that the war in
ukraine could last for years and indeed
the president putin may choose to use
weapons of mass destruction to break the
deadlock
the financial times says that the price
of gas in europe has risen by another 10
per cent
after russia's decision to turn off
supplies to poland and bulgaria
and the mail claims an exclusive with
news that police may yet hold a full
enquiry into allegations that labour
leader kier starmer broke lockdown rules
when he was filmed drinking with party
officials
loads coming up on the show this morning
i'll be speaking to the chairman of the
health and social care committee this
man jeremy hunt getting his reaction to
yesterday's care homes ruling as well as
on reforming the nhs compensation scheme
i'll be speaking to the boss of the
company that owns the steel plant in the
besieged ukrainian city of mariupol
where the city's last defenders and some
civilians still remain
[Music]
just after eight we'll be getting the
views of the shadow working pension
secretary jonathan
now a home office minister has told sky
news that a conservative mp who
allegedly watched pornography on his
mobile phone in the commons chamber
should be expelled from the party of the
claims are true the government's chief
whip has launched an investigation into
the allegations and it has been referred
to parliament's independent complaints
and grievance scheme rachel mclean who
is the minister responsible for
safeguarding women says the alleged
behaviour is both shocking and
unacceptable
i don't know the name but the chief whip
of course is going to of course he's
investigating it already he's already
said that he said that as soon as the
allegation was made uh action needs to
be taken i very much hope that this
person will be
we'll see him out of parliament out of
the party so you think that he'll be out
you'd like to see him out of parliament
i would hope that's where we get to but
i mean of course we have to hear the
full facts of the case we've only heard
one side of the story but that's already
that's already starting to happen but i
just want to be clear it's completely
and utterly shocking and unacceptable
uh also making the news a 50 year old
man is to appear in court this morning
charged with the murder of a missing
mother of two katy kenyon a huge search
operation is still underway in gisborne
forest
to try and find the 33 year olds katie's
sister said the family have lost a mum a
daughter a sister
an auntie a niece a granddaughter and a
friend
councillors in york have unanimously
voted to revoke prince andrew's freedom
of the city status after his legal
settlement over allegations of sexual
abuse the honor was given as a wedding
present back in 1987. both buckingham
palace and a spokesman for the duke
declined to comment
the government will today set out plans
to sell channel 4 the publicly owned but
commercially funded broadcaster
established in the 1980s this will be
included in proposed reforms to
decades-old broadcasting regulations
to put traditional broadcasters on an
even playing field with the streaming
networks
the chancellor rishi sunak has warned
energy companies could face a windfall
tax on profits if they don't support the
economy by increasing investment in
energy security in a wide ranging
interview with mumsnet he hinted there
could be further help for families
struggling with soaring energy bills in
the autumn
a minnesota state agency says it will
work with the city of minneapolis to
resolve the pattern of race
discrimination uncovered by a two-year
investigation it was launched after
george floyd was killed by a minneapolis
police officer the report found a
pattern of race discrimination lasting
at least the past decade
the courts in the johnny depp and amber
hard defamation trial saw a bizarre
deposition from the former couple's
concierge the actor is suing his ex-wife
for 50 million dollars for a domestic
abuse article she wrote in the
washington post which never actually
mentioned him she's counter-suing for a
hundred million disguise claire gregory
has been taking a look
sweets sketchbooks and smiles on the way
in
but a serious toning call
we just need to come in and make sure
that everybody's okay body cam footage
was shown of police officers responding
to a call in may 2016. apparently their
last row before they broke up one was
asked about red marks on the actress's
face
knowing what our investigation revealed
no it's that pink's consistent with
brian
johnny depp and amber heard's former
agent gave evidence
christian carino says after playing
captain jack sparrow five times in the
pirates of the caribbean films he
believes the actor lost the role in the
upcoming sixth movie because of amber
heard's allegations of abuse
i don't recall whether either of us ever
said anything specific about
why
but
it is something within the industry that
is
understood
another witness seems so fed up he gave
his testimony while driving
i'm tired
i don't want to deal with this court
case i everybody got problems
and i don't want to deal with this no
more
that was a first i'm sorry
but with several weeks to go there'll be
plenty more people dragged grudgingly
into this messy legal battle claire
gregory sky news
time for a quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure stays close to britain and
ireland throughout the bank holiday
weekend keeping conditions largely
settled
and weakening a rain belt that's moving
south on saturday it's a cold start to
the day
a frost in plenty of the rural parts
cloudier conditions in the east will
mean a milder start there at through the
morning
the best of the sunshine will be in the
west with temperatures recovering to
near average values scotland's central
belt and the northeast along with
scotland britain will become quite warm
with a daytime high of 16 or 17 celsius
63 degrees fahrenheit winds light for
most but southernmost counties and the
south west likely to be quite breezy
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now who's in the mood for something out
of this world
well this is the moment that four new
astronauts arrived at the international
space station on a mission between nasa
and spacex it is the first nasa crew
comprised equally of men and women and
includes jessica watkins the first black
woman making a long-term stint in space
uh but let's take a look at some of the
pictures around today this is fantastic
there's an animal theme linking all of
them this morning at first up we have
this truly terrifying picture in the
times at crowned underwater photographer
of the year lewis jeffries managed to
snap a shot of this well magnificent you
could also insert scary compass
jellyfish where is it somewhere
presumably in the caribbean nah it's off
the coast of falmouth and cornwall so
good luck guys
next up the telegraph well it has a
picture of a cow in a face mask is great
this uh no it's not trying to avoid
covid it's actually a new invention
designed to capture the methane that's
released when the cow burps a very
amusing way to reduce global warming i'd
have thought it would have been better
on the other end uh finally though uh
from one farm animal to another with
this picture in today's daily mail
firefighters were forced to get creative
after five sheep uh we're only picturing
oh yeah one two you can just make out
the fourth one in the middle there uh
they were stuck in a rooftop in west
yorkshire luckily they were able to
shepherd the flock back down to safety
still ahead i'm going to be joined by
the chair of the commons health and
social care committee and of course
former health secretary jeremy hunt
group of mps calling for the nhs
compensation scheme to be radically
overhauled that's next
welcome back let me just remind you as
to our top stories and the foreign
secretary says that russia must be
completely driven out of ukraine
comments backed up by the defense
secretary a little earlier in the
program
there are calls for an unnamed
conservative mp to be expelled from the
party if it's true that he watched
pornography whilst sitting in the house
of commons chamber parliament's
independent complaints and grievance
scheme has been asked to investigate
and police in lancashire have charged a
50 year old man with the murder of
missing mother of two katy kenyon a
search operation is still underway in
gisborne forest katie's sister said the
family have lost a mum a daughter a
sister an auntie a niece a granddaughter
and a friend
[Music]
uh well as mentioned a little earlier
the defense secretary ben wallace told
me a desperate vladimir putin was trying
to broaden the war
well i think it it's certainly the case
that putin having failed in nearly all
his objectives may seek to consolidate
what he's got sort of fortify and dig in
as he did in 2014
and just be a sort of cancerous growth
within the country of ukraine uh and
make it very hard for people to move
them out of those fortified positions so
i think it it's really about if if if we
want this to not happen we have to help
the ukrainians effectively get the
limpet off the rock
and keep the momentum pushing them back
guys ali fortescue is with us in the
studio good to see you this morning i
mean in part ben wallace was giving that
answer because of comments made by liz
trust suggesting that this conflict and
potentially our involvement could be
lasting years yeah that's right he said
that we could be in for the long haul i
think there were two really interesting
parts of his answer the first was
echoing really what liz trust saying
said last night he said that the
sovereignty of ukraine um that they
support it so much that that of course
includes crimea so that's quite a thing
to suggest that potentially we're
looking at taking back crimea which of
course was annexed by russia back in
2014. the second interesting thing was
about the defense budget liz trust last
night suggesting two percent should be a
flaw not a ceiling he said at the moment
he is happy with the budget but
suggested that things could change quite
quickly um things like inflation might
change but he i think was more measured
than we saw let's trust our site on that
potentially potentially for now much
more thank you very much much more from
ali fortescue uh in uh well later on the
program and now the nhs compensation
scheme is not fit for purpose according
to a report by mps who say that the
system needs to be radically overhauled
they say under the current scheme
accessing compensation is slow
adversarial stressful and often bitter
joining is now the chairman of the
commons health and social care committee
and of course former health secretary
himself jeremy hunt mr hunt lovely to
have you on the program i i wonder if we
might just start by giving an overview
of of the rep of the committee's
conclusions i mean it's it's been pretty
clear for some time that there needed to
be some reform of nhs litigation
thank you good morning neil um this
might seem a rather sort of technical
area um and it's very important to say
from the outset that the vast majority
of nhs care is is absolutely excellent
totally safe but when things do go wrong
we're very bad at learning from mistakes
and making sure the same thing doesn't
happen again in the future and one of
the reasons is the litigation system we
have which can mean that families have
to wait five six seven years before they
actually get an answer as to whether
they're going to get any compensation
it's absolutely devastating for them and
it costs the nhs over two billion pounds
every year to pay these claims
the biggest hospital in the nhs is
bart's trust
that's more than the entire annual cost
of paying for every single doctor and
nurse in bart's that we're paying in
compensation in litigation costs
rather than on frontline care and that's
why we're saying there needs to be an
urgent overhaul
what then in your mind needs to be done
i mean you're absolutely right to say
that you know lessons haven't been
learned in the past you only need to
look as far as the auckland report for
that so so what needs to be done and be
done pretty quickly
the first thing we say is that the
priority needs to be to learn from
mistakes
and to do that we need to make it much
easier for patients to get compensation
ironically if you make it easier for
people to get compensation you learn
from mistakes and it ends up costing you
less because these things don't then
happen again a few months or years later
and we looked at systems in new zealand
and in sweden which actually end up
costing their health systems about half
what it costs us here in the nhs and
that's because they they just make it
easier for people to access compensation
here you have to prove that a doctor or
nurse has been clinically negligent
before you get any compensation and what
that means is you have a very
adversarial process right from the start
the the medics feel very very defensive
they don't want to talk openly because
they're they're worried that there may
be professional consequences for them
and right from the outset you get a very
negative atmosphere when actually what
everyone wants to do is to be completely
transparent about what happened learn
the mistakes and make sure these
terrible tragedies aren't repeated
and this is the thing isn't it
ultimately at the core of this the nhs
held up by everyone but pretty much
everyone in this country
as one of the things that we are so most
proud of to be british it also has to be
it also has to be mentioned that
mistakes are made mistakes are
compounded by cover-ups i i just wonder
whether or not you think that the system
is hindered or it benefits from the kind
of the decentralized control of the
health service by giving control to kind
of the nhs trust is there more or less
of an attempt by by individual hospitals
to cover up their mistakes
well it's a very good question i'm
generally in favor of giving more
autonomy to hospitals and gp surgeries
just to get on with the job but i think
in this case the law gets in the way and
it makes it very difficult if someone
wants to i mean if you're a doctor or a
nurse and something goes wrong the first
thing you want to do is to be honest
with families about what happened uh to
be completely open about it but your
lawyers are telling you if you do that
uh you could be hauled in front of the
general medical council
you could lose your license to practice
you could cost us huge amounts of money
and there's one other thing that is
really outrageous in the law and really
against the founding principles of the
nhs which is that if the child of a
banker
is severely disabled because of a
mistake they will get more compensation
than the child of a cleaner
because extraordinarily the way the law
works is it looks at the likely future
earnings of that child and it decides
that the child of the banker would have
been likely to earn more in the future
that to me goes right against the
founding principle of equality that
underlines the way the nhs works and we
should change that as well
um i wonder mr hull if we can kind of
stay on your brief such as it is but get
you get your your kind of experience as
a former health sector and of course you
know when i'm going with this the high
court decision the high court uh
judicial review yesterday of matt
hancock's decision to move uh people
elderly people from hospitals uh into
care homes
the prime minister said yesterday at
pmqs that the government wasn't told of
concerns about asymptomatic transmission
by public health england and that's
nonsense isn't it
well i think the first thing to say is
that the you know to be prime minister
or health secretary in a pandemic is an
incredibly challenging thing you're
having to make decisions very quickly
and you are going to make some mistakes
and i think we have to be reasonable and
think about the context that matt
hancock and boris johnson were operating
in
our select committee looked at this
report in detail and we concluded
similarly to yesterday's judgment that
we should have done much more to learn
from what happened in countries like
germany and hong kong
where when people were sent to care
homes for example in germany they had to
be isolated for three months unless
there was a negative test uh we didn't
do that here that was clearly a mistake
but i think the broader issue and it's
one that i have to bear my share of
responsibility for as well as someone
who has health secretary for six years
is that we just still have not sorted
out problems in the social care system
so when you have a crisis
it always ends up playing second fiddle
to the nhs the focus of if i may say
you'll also the media but the
politicians the civil servants the
system is on hospitals and hospital care
and that's what everyone is thinking
about
and
what happened
i would counter that we probably
wouldn't have known as quickly as we did
what was going on in our care homes if
it wasn't for the media including people
like our people in politics
correspondent nick martin getting in
there i mean the problem is i think i
suppose mr hunt is we can't deal with
this as an abstraction you know by june
of 2020 there were perhaps as many as 30
000 excess deaths and care homes and in
part that was as a result of a decision
taken by the health the then health
secretary seemingly unaware of advice
that if he'd switched on the today
program he'd have heard sir patrick
violence giving
yes and so i wasn't saying that the
media didn't have a very very important
role during the i was being somewhat
cheeky i was being somewhat cheap
but i think the the interesting thing is
actually if you look at the high court
judgment the advice the health secretary
received from officials
didn't advise him that he should think
about this question of asymptomatic
transmission so there was a kind of
group think in the system that said that
this uh virus we were dealing with was
going to be essentially like the flu
virus where you don't think so much
about asymptomatic transmission i think
there are lots and lots of lessons to be
learned but the broader point i really
wanted to make is that until we really
fix the problems in the care system
then i think we're always going to find
the center of gravity in a crisis
remains hospitals and the nhs
and that in this case had devastating
consequences
mr hunt away from away from health
entirely and what do you make of the
reports that the one of your
parliamentary colleagues uh one of your
conservative party colleagues i should
actually say um was seen by his
colleagues watching pornography on his
mobile phone in the house of commons
chamber
well to be honest i just feel so
disappointed um i'm disappointed that it
it was someone in my party that was
alleged to have done this
but also disappointed for the house of
commons as an institution i have to say
my day-to-day experience as an mp is not
that this kind of thing is happening on
a regular basis but i just feel we
should not be putting female mps through
this kind of ordeal and it's totally and
utterly unacceptable and
clearly we have to have a very big
culture change and um you know and i
hope
if there is some good that comes out of
this it will prompt that culture change
that many people have been calling for
jeremy hunt always great to have you on
the program appreciate your time
thank you thank you
a little bit of breaking news for you
now uh we're just learning that a man
has been charged with four murders in
south london uh aged 28 joshua jacks has
been charged with the murder of four
family members stabbed to death
in that terrorist house in barminsi
according to the metropolitan police
the russian president vladimir putin has
vowed
that his special military operation in
ukraine will guarantee the safety of
people in the donbass and crimea but as
forces continue their assault on the
donetsk region our correspondent alex
rossi sent this report from the town of
savero donetsk that finds itself under
well near continuous bombardment
there is absolutely nowhere here that's
been spared
street after street it's the same
shattered buildings and bomb craters
the front-line city of sivera donetsk is
a key target for russian forces
and it's been under attack since day one
of this invasion
the people here survive on handouts
there's no power or running water
most have left and those staying only
come up from their basements when the
shelling stops
at the main police station the ukrainian
flag still flies proudly
this building's been targeted again and
again but the resistance remains strong
this is the second floor
of the police building it's still very
much
under ukrainian control but this area is
heavily contested at the moment
and there isn't really any part of this
city
that hasn't been hit by
russian attacks
this was an airstrike
now nobody was killed incredibly and the
police are managing to still work
out of the rest of this building
but it's a scene of absolute devastation
everyone in this city is struggling in
the face of unrelenting savagery
as we visit the only working hospital
the sound of fighting gets closer
inside the medics do what they can
they're treating the war wounded and
routine emergencies people don't stop
getting sick because they're shooting
outside
all of the patients are treated in the
corridors away from the windows which
have been blown out by shells
this hospital has been attacked more
than 20 times
is recovering from shrapnel wounds but
she's defiant and has this message for
vladimir putin
and after we left we received these
images from medics
the hospital had been shelled again and
one of the patients was killed
it is another reminder of the brutal
nature of russia's war
where the innocent are all too often the
victims
alex rossi sky news eastern ukraine
potentially thousands of civilians and
troops remained trapped in a steel plant
in ukraine the azov style complex uh
well it's situated in the besieged city
of mario paul in the south of ukraine
and local officials say the plant is
once again
under russian
bombardment uh joining me now yuri
rosenkoff the ceo of met invest holding
which owns the as of style steel plant
in mario paul um yuri thank you so much
for taking the time to talk to us this
morning i really appreciate it and i i
just wonder if you can give us
any up-to-date information of what you
know to be the situation in and around
the steel plant you must suspect that
there are several thousand of your
employees still there
well unfortunately we don't even know
how many of our employees are still at
the plant uh
the situation there is
i would say humanitarian catastrophe uh
the food and water that was prepared by
us in the shelters is probably over
and the russians
since the beginning of the war did not
allow any people to leave safely the
place
despite their announcements of so-called
green corridors
they never worked so whenever people
tried to get out uh they were shot at uh
so
so i i i think it's it's a real tragedy
which is happening there right now
yeah as we just look at the pictures of
the bombarded steel plant you looking i
don't know if you can see these pictures
but you will have seen the damage that
has been done
to your resource i i just heard you
mention though that there was there was
you had stocked food and water at the
plant in advance of the the the russian
invasion
that's correct uh we've been uh uh
inside in contact with the russian
invasion since 2014 one of our factories
in nordica has been close to the
dividing line for a long time so we
always kept the bomb shelters in good
order we always kept at least two two to
three weeks stocks of food and water
there
that allowed people of marijuana to to
stay there for such a long time
how long in terms of um how long in
terms of food and water did you did you
think that you had in stocks at the at
the steel plant of course this has been
going on now for in excess of 60 70 days
i think
that's correct well specifically as of
style has bomb shelters enough to to to
give cover to about 4 000 people
and we stocked food and water which is
enough with the normal uh ration for for
about three weeks
but now as we rightly said it's it's uh
it's almost two months and i'm pretty
sure that stocks are running out
when was the last time that you had any
direct contact with people at the steel
plant yuri
well the last direct contact was some
time ago when we still had some of our
employees with satellite phones and they
were able to contact us but we're daily
meeting some people that managed to get
out at their own uh risk from from from
the plant and get out of marijuana and
get to to our help centers to our
rehabilitation centers in zappos
and we're talking to them and they're
telling us the stories what's happening
there
what happens if if the worst happens in
your mind yuri if the russians do manage
to take mario paul and of course take
take the steel plan what then happens to
any employees of yours that are theirs i
mean can you see yourselves working
under russian occupation well we uh
always proclaimed in our shareholder
not work inaudib the russian occupation
mad investor is a company or none of sem
group companies will work under the
russian occupation that goes for
mariupol as well
i hope that as many as possible our
employees will
get out of this uh occupied uh city
we are greeting them in zappos we have a
rehabilitation center we have uh
providing them with the food with the uh
closes with the psychiatrists
and and also we we're providing with the
new place of work so hopefully as many
as possible fireplace we'll get out of
there
yuri i wonder if we might just speak
more generally about by the conflict
that you have seen i just wonder what
your views are of the russians of
vladimir putin given what has happened
in mario paul given what has happened in
butcher kharkiv in so many places in and
around ukraine
i mean
seeing what i've seen there is is very
difficult to to express the words what i
think about about them but uh
um
i'm i'm pretty sure that by doing so uh
mr putin has
made a huge damage to ukraine but he
destroyed russia
and the russian for generations they
will pay for that
do you see a peaceful end to this
conflict any time soon given
well the latest that we are hearing is
that vladimir putin's ambitions might
not be limited of course just to ukraine
moldova is now starting to look slightly
slightly concerning
that's correct but but we already see
the world uniting uh around ukraine to
to basically to stop this russian
aggression and uh
i mean we we've learned from the second
world war uh when the world unites
none of the aggressors ever are able to
win
uh yuri roshonkov thank you so much for
talking to us this time we do hope that
your employees are safe and well in
those bunkers
thank you very much
we're just looking ahead to events
taking place later on today in about
half an hour's time we are expecting the
foreign ministry spokesperson maria
zakharova to hold her weekly news
briefing we would expect some lines
coming from that given that she was the
person along with vladimir putin
threatening the uk directly for as she
saw it at james tp earlier this week
encouraging the ukrainians to strike
targets inside russia indeed stay where
you are after the break i will be
bringing you all the latest from ukraine
another key event today the head of the
un arriving in the ukrainian capital for
talks with vladimir zelansky
[Music]